you can use the alerting feature in
Google Cloud monitoring to be notified
when issues or failures occur within
your application to create your first
alerting policy look for the creative
rule alerting policy button on your
dashboard or via the alerting menu at
the top of the screen when you create
your first policy you'll begin by giving
it a name in this case I'll call it test
policy you may want to choose a more
descriptive name given that this is
included in any notifications about
alerts next you select the type of
condition under which the policy will
trigger a notification in this case
we'll use a metric threshold condition
which is to describe a case where I want
to be alerted when a metric crosses a
threshold for a period of time I'm an
app engine user and in this case I want
to be alerted related to an app engine
module so I'll select the app engine
module resource type and I'm concerned
with a single module so I'll say single
and then I'll choose the module for the
policy in this case it's the comments
module I click Next
then I select the metric that I want to
evaluate in this case I could have
chosen total responses or 500 responses
but I'm primarily concerned right now
with response latencies 95th percentile
I select that metric and I see a preview
of the metric down the bottom of the
screen which shows that metrics
performance over the last hour in this
case I want to be alerted if the 95th
percentile response latency is above 900
milliseconds again I see a preview of
that threshold on the chart and I'll
choose to be alerted if it stays above
that level for five minutes and that's
it I'll save my condition
next I should choose how I want to be
notified when the alert is triggered I
can be notified
via email SMS or popular services such
as pager duty HipChat campfire or slack
in this case we'll choose email and I
simply enter the email address and then
save the alert now I'll be notified if
my 95th percentile latency for my
comments module exceeds the threshold
for five minutes